[Music]
superheroes versus videogame characters
The Incredible Hulk vs. King Koopa
here's my reason why Cooper would win
sure the Hulk is big and strong Cooper's
not really strong he's just big but he
could shoot fireballs and the Hulk is
not immune to fireball
okay says Jeff who's wrong but let's say
let's even imagine let's imagine that
fireballs could hurt the Incredible Hulk
okay they would they would they let's
just imagine they were let's imagine
that they would happen and let's let's
even let's even get rid of the fact that
that would just make the Incredible Hulk
mad which makes him more powerful let's
just talk about this number of short
Italian men who killed the Incredible
Hulk zero fam nobody's killed Koopa he
keeps coming back he keeps coming back
like a rubber band at the barn
ring I'm back every time comes back a
lot - I'm saying incredible only back
once ass okay once more they really come
back he rose but that's all another
issue that came back he was dead Holly
he was high and I said highs okay
guys oh I'm like JC and dude JC here was
like I'm just saying a King Koopa
wouldn't even stand chance he can't even
keep a woman in his castle a Ally
Sheedy fireballs
alright in Mario Kart he's one of the
slowest Mario is actually what do we get
immune to frickin fireballs oh he's not
can't push Koopa off the track okay the
lobby you can't push I bought that
this one's at I know what girl time it's
not know I had at I know if this is
stupid
he's right powerful person in the Marvel
Universe he Koopa wouldn't even last a
minute you just saying this to piss its
high you're just trying to piss me off
no I think all right next fireballs
versus strength anyway here we go we're
gonna poop what can hide he just crawls
into his shell he can't hide this is
what pulls us arms in the Incredible
Hulk would rip the shell apart like it
was paint because it'd be fireballs
spitting out of it which wouldn't do
anything yes because the Hulk is not
immune to fire the Hulk is immune to
fire oh my god he's on fire it kind of
hurts him but his healing factor so fast
he would have been healed by the time
even simply
the word healing fact has a healing
factor it's bad it's like credit roll
roll for critical resistance all right
fine
okay
[Music]
you